We wanted to let you know here
at the top of today’s episode
that Journey to the Microcosmos is now on TikTok.
You can think of our TikToks like the
fun size candy bar of Microcosmos.
You will still find your full length,
full size Microcosmos here on YouTube,
but if you’re looking for a
quick little Microcosmos snack,
you can check us out on TikTok, where
we are @journeytothemicrocosmos.
Given the manyfascinating
single-celled organisms that we have seen
on our journey through the microcosmos,
it would be easy to mistake this for yet another
fascinating, spiky ciliate—perhaps something
related to a suctorian, but with an unusually
giant organelle pulsating within its boundaries.
But this is not a single-celled organism.
This… is an egg, which is
also a thrilling sight for us.
Eggs are incredible.
Whether they are kept within
the confines of their mother,
or—as with this one—released into the
world, the egg is all about what comes next.
Within its confines are cells that divide
and differentiate, gathering in numbers while
creating their own individual identities that will
become organs and tissue in the animal to come.
And you can see the animal moving around in its
egg, restless and perhaps ready to hatch.
And when it does, it will take on the
cumulative identity of all those cells,
in this case, an animal that we call
the Gastrotrich.
The Gastrotrich has long been a personal favorite
microbe of several members of the
Journey to the Microcosmos crew.
They were one of the first microbes
we dedicated an entire episode to,
and many of us came away charmed by
their hairy, dragon-shaped bodies.
But while we were able to see a lot
with the microscopes we had at the time,
James—our master of microscopes—has made some
significant upgrades since then (thanks
in part to the support of many of you).
And this means that we are now able to see
gastrotrichs in a whole new light.
So while before, we could see the hair
traveling down the length of their bodies,
and even make out the organs within them,
now it’s like you can touch them.
Like if you run your finger along them,
you will feel the prickle of scales and the
feathery brush of hairs against your skin.
And to be honest, that was our main
reason for wanting to revisit them today.
But while we are here, perhaps we should revisit
the gastrotrich more generally.
If you haven’t watched it before
(or just want a refresher),
feel free to take a moment now
to rewatch it if you’d like.
We will still be here when you’re done.
But if you’d rather stick around, the main
thing you need to know is that we titled that
episode “Four Day Old Grandmothers,”
because for some gastrotrich species,
reproduction operates on a very rushed timeline.
Those species are members of the order Chaetonida,
which sets them in contrast to the other
order of Gastrotrichs, the Macrodasyida.
While almost all of gastrotrichs across
both orders can reproduce sexually,
the Chaetonids have an additional
approach: parthenogenesis.
This means that they are able to form
an embryo from an unfertilized egg.
The reason we’re revisiting the specifics of
gastrotrich reproduction is because it might be
related to another fundamental difference between
Chaetonids and Macrodasyoids: their habitats.
Chaetonids are largely found in freshwater, while
Macrodasyoids are mostly found in marine waters.
Scientists have long wondered
just how Gastrotrichs found
themselves in these different environments.
It’s generally accepted that the order
Macrodasyida is older than the order Chaetonida.
That suggests that Gastrotrichs began
as an order of marine animals, which
then went through some evolutionary pathway that
transitioned some of them into freshwater life.
There are many questions that
we could ask about that transition.
Where did the gastrotrichs’ journey take them?
Did this evolution happen
several times, or just once?
Did changes on a geologic
scale—like changes in sea
level—shape these long-lasting
changes within their bodies?
Is the journey of Chaetonids
into freshwater complete,
or did any ever venture their
way back to marine environments?
Well when scientists used the tools of molecular
phylogeny, they found evidence that the shift
from marine to freshwater life happened just
once, and that it happened fairly quickly.
And it may be that parthenogenesis
made that change possible.
If some of those gastrotrichs in transition
had been able to reproduce via parthenogenesis,
they may have had a significant advantage
as they settled in a new environment.
Without having to go through
the trouble of fertilization,
they could have quickly expanded their population,
gaining a foothold that allowed them to survive.
Now we don’t know if parthenogenesis
did directly drive the chaetonids’
ability to transition into freshwater, but
there is evolutionary precedent for it.
Mud snails shifted to parthenogenetic reproduction
in their own marine-to-freshwater transition.
But parthenogenesis is just one of the traits that
might have allowed these species
to spread into less salty waters.
They would have required other adaptations,
changes that would allow them to tolerate
the shifting landscape in the
ecology and geology around them.
Scientists have also found that there are
some marine gastrotrichs among the
otherwise freshwater chaetonids.
It might seem like this relationship
means those marine gastrotrichs are
remnants of the ancient gastrotrichs
who set the stage for freshwater life.
But that’s not what the genetics say.
Instead, it appears that these marine
gastrotrichs are the result of chaetonids who
decided that freshwater life wasn’t for them,
who returned to the saltier
environments of their ancestors.
What drove those gastrotrichs back?
Well aside from the fact that there
was an evolutionary space for them.
We don’t know.
Animals have been navigating new environments
and finding ways to adapt for eons,
each organism always laying the foundation for
new ways of living, building a biology so complex
that even the tiniest bits of it are worth of
the sort of intense, unrelenting investigation
that humans are so very, very good at.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The people on the screen right
now, those are our Patreon patrons.
They're the people who make this channel
possible, and who allow us to just really
unleash our unrelenting investigation into
this tiny, tiny world that so much deserves it.
We're really excited to continue
that investigation into 2023,
and the reason we can do
it, is our Patreon patrons.
So if you want to add your name onto this list,
you can go to Patreon.com/JournytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our
master of microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us,
there's always a subscribebutton somewhere nearby.